Americans are being ordered to practice
social distancing to help slow the
spread of the coronavirus but in crowded
cities across the country that is not
always easy to do so it is not in small
places small spaces at home have pushed
many people outside but busy grocery and
convenience stores are now forced to
find creative ways to keep those people
apart our national correspondent Jericka
Duncan is looking at some of these
challenges drink oh good morning there's
a pizza place in my neighborhood with a
takeout window and they've spray-painted
on the sidewalk no standing here I
definitely believe that people are
making are going to be helpful you know
in the end in both New York State and
California government officials are
starting to really come down hard on
crowds at outdoor spaces like parks and
beaches in fact the governor of
California is now shutting down all
parking at state parks to help
discourage visitors and in Los Angeles
city officials there have also warned
that law enforcement officers will not
be shy when it comes to enforcing the
rules in cities where space is already
tight staying at least six feet apart
from other people has become
increasingly challenging you almost
accidentally don't do it a bunch of
times because you forget and then you
have to like take a step back mat Zender
in Seattle says he was initially
surprised by grocery store policies to
help keep customers at a distance
several major chains are limiting the
amount of people allowed inside others
are adding visual cues like these tape
squares to space out customers waiting
in line or placing large crates in front
of registers to keep people away from
cashiers it's so helpful if we can
implement policy controls and
environmental controls that help people
alter our behavior carolyn kinesio is
the director of research at the center
for public health initiatives at the
University of Pennsylvania
she says the other key to social
distancing in cities is timing if we
need to go out for exercise we need to
try to do that at times when the public
parks or paths are not very busy if we
need to go to the grocery store we
should try to either order ahead
and just pick up the groceries or to go
at non busy times another major problem
is people simply ignoring orders to stay
home crowding Los Angeles beaches Bay
Area hiking trails or new york city
parks and prompting officials to add new
restrictions I think people are
definitely taking advantage of going to
the beach and still congregating in
groups which now in turn is kind of
ruined it for the rest of us I start to
see more and more people in parks
together not really holding on to that
six feet away rule at all canoe Co
reminds people that outside of your home
you should have as little contact as
possible with others I think people let
their guard down when they see people
who are familiar to them they don't
hesitate to visit the homes of friends
familiarity does not confer protection
so here's some other things to consider
when you're going grocery shopping shop
for a few days so you don't have to
continuously make trips back and forth
to the grocery store and another thing
is try to hide your phone away from
yourself when your grocery shopping why
is that because the ideas you go grocery
shopping then you come home then you
wash your hands and then you can deal
with your phone or maybe even leave your
phone at home that's good advice she's
right
I like Tony what you said about your
pizza shop because I went to CVS the
other day to get my cholesterol medicine
they have a little table in front so you
have to reach over like that just to get
it I like that they're taking all the
precautions they're taking yeah I think
that's very important it's very hard
though because you know New Yorkers
particularly in a time of crisis they're
used to going up to other New Yorkers
and being like how are ya you know we
come together and now it's new finding
I've like I got a grad I've got the
opposite of a gravitational pull it's
like I see somebody and I like back away